now a question for you what do you do if
you have lots of a product that no one
wants the price dives and your stocks
become worthless that's what's happened
to oil thanks to the corona virus
pandemic demand is low but storage
facilities are full on Monday it got
even worse the price went negative
meaning that traders were paying
customers to take the stuff away the
corona virus pandemic has brought
economies around the world to a halt
along with a demand for oil after weeks
of tumbling prices crude dropped below
zero for the first time
producers literally can't give it away
an agreement last week between leading
oil-producing nations to slash output
clearly failed to address worries about
a huge glut of oil this is quite a lot
to do with the weak consumer demand I
think we've got a an economic disaster
coming ahead of us also right now all
we're doing is dealing with the lack of
traveling from these lockdown measures
so people aren't going to work people
aren't dropping their kids to school
nobody's flying anywhere and that's
really causing a demand problem
and since storage facilities have filled
up oil is now practically worth nothing
for more details let's speak to a
business reporter Rob Watts who brought
us at that report Rob welcome so what
exactly do negative oil prices mean well
imagine after the show we go to a shop
say it's open to buy a chocolate bar and
we go to the shopkeeper and we say how
much is this chocolate bar and he says -
1 euro we'd be very pleasantly surprised
because what that would mean is that
he's going to give us a chocolate bar
and he's going to give us a euro as well
it sounds preposterous but that is the
position that we found ourselves in with
us
oil yesterday basically producers were
having to pay buyers to take it off
their hands since the start of the
corona virus outbreak people haven't
been flying they've not been driving all
these things require oil so oil demand
has fallen greatly but production hasn't
fallen by the same amount
so it's meant that producers have got
this backlog of oil it's starting to
cost a lot of money to store that oil
they've been having to rent tankers off
the US coast to put it on and it's
reached the point where it's more
expensive to keep it than it is to sell
it so they've been having to literally
pay people to take it off their hands
and and handle the storage costs instead
a friend described it as the barrel
costing more than the oil that's within
it but then just on the point that you
were making why is production continuing
when there's clearly no demand yeah well
this is something that you know nations
around the world have been arguing about
over the past few weeks we did have this
agreement between the OPEC nations and
their allies to cut global production by
10 million barrels a day a couple of
weeks ago turns out that's not enough to
cut it by but also in the US companies
there have been reluctant to cut their
own production there are certain costs
associated with doing that they also
don't want to give their competitors a
chance to overtake them so production
has continued even though they can't
sell the stuff fast enough so it's going
through the refineries but it's got
nowhere to go it's an interesting
example you gave about the chocolate bar
I would love to get a chocolate and be
paid one euro for it
so if I'm a normal consumer oil is
effectively free that's a good thing is
it well it's a good thing for drivers in
the u.s. at the moment actually it's
already been a good thing all year for
the US since the start of January petrol
prices that are fallen by 2/3 so drivers
are having a great time of it there at
least they were when they were allowed
out on the roads now there are much
fewer people on the roads the petrol
price is very low but where are you
going to drive how are you going to use
that petrol so we can expect the petrol
prices to still be low when the economy
does start to get going again in the
United States lower than they were
before the corona virus outbreak but as
people would take to the roads again
those prices are going to go back up you
can have the oil lab and do nothing with
it that's an interesting dilemma to be
in robots thanks so much for explaining
that to us